oh hello old friend back once again with
modern era Doctor Who episodes that I
don't already have reviews up for it's
overdue Doctor Who review I'm think I
might finally be getting used to saying
that I did okay at that time so we are
up to Dalek
so this one many people regard as the
best show the best episode of series one
some people even regarded as one of the
best episodes of modern Doctor Who
period and it is really good it has this
reputation for a reason on the rewatch
though I found myself surprisingly
underwhelmed with a couple of key
elements now I want to say a couple
things before I get into this one is
it's possible that in some ways my
opinion has diminished because I've now
listen to the big fitty the Big Finish
audio drama Jubilee which this is more
or less adapted from or at least two
significant portions of it are and is
written by the same writer Robert
Sherman so having now basically gotten
the full version because jubblies about
two hours long versus kind of the Cliff
Notes version that it's possible that
that's tainting it but I think there's
something else at play here
but I'm gonna come back to that cuz
let's let's stick to the good stuff
first of all in terms of reintroducing
the Daleks for the modern era yeah job
totally accomplished they are given the
weight that they should have they the
this Dalek is dangerous it is
methodical and interestingly enough I
actually watched this with my partner
Liz who I'm slowly getting into Doctor
Who not in front to back I'm kind of
curating a playlist of episodes for her
so that this one we watched together and
so this was her first encounter with the
Daleks and she and she said something
that I'm not sure I had thought of but I
was like yeah you're right and she was
like you know it's kind of more
terrifying the fact that it doesn't move
quickly and she's not wrong it doesn't
have to move quickly it's still gonna
get you and it's still gonna kill you so
that wasn't that I thought that was cool
but she she um understood why it was
scary and it was nice to get an outside
perspective because another thing she
said was you know when I first saw it
I'm like really but then by the time the
episode was over she's like no I get it
so I think that's what this episode does
really well it doesn't shy away from the
ridiculous you have Adam call it a
pepper pot you have you know somebody
make fun of the sucker you have oh it
can't go all upstairs and all of this
slowly dismantled over time as you see
the scope and the capabilities and the
deadliness of this thing as it it's all
unfurled over time it's not all of a
sudden oh it starts killing things
because then it would just be a
ridiculous looking pepper pot that kills
things like know what it is capable of
it keeps ramping up as the whole story
moves forward so it makes it I think a
really brilliant way to reintroduce the
Daleks into the modern era and in front
of an audience that by and large you
know may have been aware of them that
they existed yes I think especially in
the UK because the the Daleks are such a
such a cultural touchstone for a long
time but like you know pop culture
hadn't taken my Daleks seriously in a
long time but this is really well
handled and really well treated so I
mean I think that is that's the ultimate
triumph of this episode is selling the
dalek and the Daleks as a race by
extension for a modern audience it does
that phenomenally well and the the
redesign is really good it's incredibly
evocative of classic Dalek design you
would not mistake it for anything else
and yet it is a little bit different it
is a little bit updated it feels you
know a little more weight to it there's
you know the lights on the side aren't
just bumps there's you know they're
they're more distinct they're more
pronounced there's a little bit more
texture going on on some of it it's it's
a nice update without being a complete
total redesign so I really appreciate
that Rose does really well this episode
I it's very interesting how you know
she's been traveling with the doctor for
a little bit but she doesn't know what
this thing is because the doctor hasn't
told her about them that the doctor
wouldn't have talked about these things
you know he's not ready he's still
dealing with the trauma at the time war
so she doesn't know what this thing is
capable of what this thing is like when
she gets near it when she touches it so
that's played pretty well because I
could have come across as a companion
being very stupid which can tend to
annoy me but it's it's all very
believable here under the circumstances
so that all works really well
I had a Mitchell as crap as he is as a
companion in the next episode I don't I
don't want to dwell too much on that
killeth talk about that when I get there
he he plays well with rose and it's
understandable why you know they would
give it a go at bringing him along if
that makes sense
based off this but for some of the other
stuff van Straten
as a character is fine
he's functional but I think that's one
of the areas where I might be a little
bit biased having now listen to Jubilee
because the the characters that they
have a Jubilee instead of Vance try
the the President of Britain and and
some of the things going on there they
have a depth to them that I think van
Straten just lacks van Straten just kind
of is what he appears to be yeah I'm not
sure he could have been done any deeper
in something that isn't a two-parter but
you know he's he's functional he's there
to be what he's meant to be and he's
well cast but I kind of obnoxious
American business type so you know he
works fine but he's not he's not a
particularly memorable or amazing guest
star oddly what I found myself thinking
was that there was something a little
off about Eccleston and Eccleston's
performance in this not always sometimes
it sometimes it really works I think
when he's talking with van Straten you
know what's the nearest City Salt Lake
City population 1 million all dead you
know when he's doing that when he's
trying to explain it to him that works
really well his scene with the Dalek
itself there's something the only thing
I can I can come up with this is
artificial there's something very well
not very it's not it's not over the over
the top as an element but there's
something ever so slightly actory lack
of a better term what I've really loved
about Eccleston in this role is there is
a naturalness to his performance and I
don't necessarily mean in terms of like
that's how real people talk I mean like
whenever he speaks it just seems to flow
very easily out of him like this is just
what this person would say here I be
much more feels like somebody reading
lines especially his scene with the
Dalek itself and his turns in his mood
at having seen it and there's nothing
wrong with you know what's being written
or even you know the emotions that he's
playing but there's something about the
transition
and through them that feel artificial
that feel like an actor who maybe was
having a little trouble figuring out
okay you know how do I get from this
line to this line there has to be a
shift and I'm not quite getting it you
know speaking of someone who's worked on
stage and has had times of where I've
had lines I'm like wait a minute how am
I supposed to get from here to here this
doesn't mean you know you work for the
directory work through rehearsals or
whatever else but you know that's for a
play when it's when you're on a TV
shooting schedule you only have so much
time to work the material and I'm
presuming and I mean you know this is
based off the performance and yes not
bad it's all good but there's just
there's just something ever so slightly
not clicking and usually he he can't
click in this but there's something
about the extremity of the emotions and
there's they don't feel like they're
coming from the place of sincerity that
he usually seems to be pulling from and
maybe it's because you know the idea of
what the time war wasn't what went on
and was very abstract I mean it's still
pretty abstract but then even more so
maybe he just couldn't latch on
something solid enough but yeah I don't
know and I feel really bad saying I'm
sure I have a feeling a ton of people
are gonna dis reveal I clumb what are
you talking about these it's the best
thing ever when he yells at the Dalek
you know why don't you just die and all
that look these are good moments none of
this is wrong but it's just to me
something's off just a little bit about
the performance in those moments I don't
know but coming off of that you know
it's it's still a very good episode it
is undoubtedly one of the best episodes
of series one um it definitely is and
it's also got great music the track the
lone Dalek I really really loved it came
this close to making my top 10 tracks by
Murray gold so it's it
that's a really great piece of music and
it's just a good episode it's a good
solid episode and I don't mean to bang
on it but it this is the first one where
I've come in and watched it again and
it's not as good as I had in my head and
maybe that's the reputation of the thing
working against me maybe that's me
building up the memory of this episode
in my head too much but yeah what I had
in my head it didn't it wasn't quite
there which makes it oddly disappointing
without it being the episodes fault
so maybe the problems of me I don't know
but in any case Daleks still a fantastic
episode of series one but I've now just
spent a little mile basically kind of
sliding off one of the most beloved
episodes of the new series certainly of
Eccleston's run so comment sections
should be fun and in he case folks what
do you think about Dalek whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about there's a
whole bunch of stuff to do such as I
don't know buttons and patreon link and
links to other stuff check them out if
you're feeling up to it remember you're
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]